Wow
snot look little gross I need to wash my
hands or something I have a crippling
fear of stitch from Lilo & Stitch female
16 I can't relate but I pray for you I
stole a $5 pair of Batman sunglasses
from the kids section at Walmart unknown
I think I've done that before
recently I got locked into my apartment
bathroom with only a towel and no
clothes I live alone so I had to scream
out the window for help female 22 that
sucks
it's kind of an embarrassing situation
cuz you'll get to know people that live
around you a little bit too quickly I
secretly hate the condo my parents
bought for me and I hate myself for
feeling that way unknown they should
hate themselves a little bit for that
one I think I offered to give a guy a
hand job at Burger King in college when
I was drunk a security guard heard me
kicked me out and told me not to come
back for one month
female 28 one time I stayed home from
school for two weeks in the sixth grade
complaining that my abdomen hurt I had
to get x-rays blood work and travel for
endometriosis tests I was just faking it
the entire time unknown why I had an
affair with the married man who's 16
years older than me he told his wife and
they're trying to work it out but he and
I continued to talk and see each other
and sleep together
female 24 I accidentally saw my mom's
medical sheet from one of her doctors
appointments it said she's had three
live births I'm the oldest of two in our
family and she has no idea I've seen it
unknown I have attempted suicide twice
and no one knows
female 21 that makes me so sad and I
just want to know who they are so I can
help them I want my girlfriend to have
sex with other people unknown it's weird
yeah I don't my girl from that sex with
other people
it became pregnant age 13 got an
abortion and trying to kill myself
there are five people in the world who
know including myself female age 16
that's really sad and I hope they're
okay now my son would probably be better
off without me unknown it's really sad
I feel more gender-fluid than completely
female though I come across as
completely femme I felt this way for a
while now and I know I won't be accepted
by my parents or my boyfriend unknown I
feel bad for that person that they can't
be truly themself I don't feel like a
woman I'm not sure if this means I'm
transgender and secure or something else
being considered a woman feels odd and
wrong I tried wearing ultra feminine
things and looked amazing but I was
faking it the entire time unknown I feel
for this person I'm rootin for you I
have dreams all the time about having
sex with my dad female 16 I don't like
my mom I say I love her because she is
my mom but she's not a good person
female 20 my friends all think I have a
pretty exciting sex life occasionally
hooking up with strangers kinky sex etc
the truth is I've never had sex male 26
I've never been in love with anyone the
closest I ever gotten was with a
fictional character female 24 I have
violent thoughts about people who
sometimes I can control them and
sometimes I can't
I'm afraid that someday I might give in
to those thoughts and hurt someone
unknown
I was molested by my older brother when
I was seven and he was 11 I've never
told anyone because he was young and he
has been such a good brother to me ever
since but it still impacts me to this
day unknown I don't even know what to do
with that I feel like I've kept secrets
and then like six years later I've had
to go into therapy for years and be like
okay got to try to figure this out now I
think I might be slowly becoming
anorexic but I'm too scared to tell
anyone when people ask why I don't eat
as much I just say I'm not hungry
I know this person obviously can sense
that something is happening and in the
process of happening but I guess it's
good that they're aware that it's
happening so maybe they'll be able to
get some help
[Music]